This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。保证真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）带来的《吃一堑长一智》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得并不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人身披全套盔甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做，请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
收听《吃一堑长一智》。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是数字2%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子约会过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
听听好姐妹的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和说是个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），在这个播客里，我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners.
无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目。本周，我们要讨论的是一个不可避免的恋爱时刻——一个我们在人生某个阶段都必然会遇到的概念，无论那是在我们20多岁的时候——通常我们第一次经历这种事就在这个时候，还是在人生的晚些时候。当我们的前任向前看时，我们该怎么办？更进一步说，为什么这会如此痛苦？我想这是一个很多人都问过自己并一直在寻找答案的问题。分手从来都不容易。我们与这个人有着情感上的羁绊和依恋，而分手后的余波会让人感到无比冲击，
wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode. This week, we're talking about an inevitable relationship moment concept that we are all going to encounter at some stage in our lives, whether that is in our 20s, which is typically when we have our first experience of this happening or later in life. What do we do when our X moves on? And further to that, Why can it be so painful? I think that that is a question that a lot of ourselves have found ourselves asking and looking for an answer to. Breakups are never easy. We are emotionally bonded and attached to this person and the aftermath can feel so confronting
就像我们正身处一片非常混乱的情感风暴中。但是，当我们看到前任继续他们的人生，似乎已经彻底放下了，放下了我们，没有受到分手的影响时，究竟发生了什么？我想这确实令人心碎，也是一段极其艰难的经历。它让我们陷入被动、渴望和困惑的情绪中，即使我们自己已经开始了一段新恋情，或者我们没有任何未了的情结，又或者已经过去好几年了。得知前任在和新人约会这一事实，有一种在心理上极具冲击力的方面。我想有时我们并不完全理解为什么会这样。所以今天的节目中，我们要讨论的就是这个。我经历过好几次。
like we're kind of navigating this storm of very confusing emotions. But what exactly happens when we see our former partner? moving forward with their life seemingly over it, over us, unaffected by the breakup. I think it can be really heart-wrenching and a really difficult experience. It leaves us grappling with feelings of rejection and longing and confusion, even if we ourselves are in a new relationship or we don't have any unresolved feelings or it's been years. There is this aspect of finding out that your ex is dating someone new, that is very psychologically confronting. And I think sometimes we don't understand exactly why that is. So in today's episode, that is exactly what we're going to talk about. I've been here quite a few times.
每一次都和上一次一样痛。但我认为，在对这些经历进行反思之后，其中也产生了一些很好的经验、智慧和成熟，希望我能分享出来。所以我们要深入探讨，为什么前任向前看这件事会带给你如此独特的冲击。特别是，我真的很想讨论我们认为这说明了什么，也许我们是可以被替代的，或者他们的新伴侣拥有我们所没有的东西，以及这究竟是如何严重伤害了我们的自我价值感和自我认知。我想在这些时刻，我们经常忘记我们为什么不和那个人在一起了，
Each of them hurt just as much as the last. But I think that upon reflecting on those experiences, there's been some good lessons and good wisdom and maturity that has come out of it that hopefully I can share. So we're going to examine exactly what it is about your ex moving on that is so uniquely confronting. In particular, I really want to discuss what we think it says about us, that perhaps we are replaceable, or that their new partner possesses something that we don't have, and how exactly that really injures our sense of self-worth and our self-concept. I think often in these moments, we forget exactly why we are not with. that person, why that relationship had to come to an end. And all we remember are the good times, the happy memories. There's this idea in psychology known as rosy retrospection. And I want to
为什么这段关系不得不走向终结。而我们能记住的只有美好的时光、快乐的回忆。心理学上有个概念叫“玫瑰幻觉”（rosy retrospection）。我想展示它是如何让我们陷入对渴望和期待的执念中的，而不是让我们真正放下并向前看。我们还将触及沉没成本、心碎成瘾模型、期待思维、社会比较等诸多概念。这里面有很多科学原理，我认为可能会非常非常有帮助。但今天节目的核心其实是：接下来呢？当这个章节终于合上时，我们该做什么？不言而喻，立刻开始一段新恋情或是找个备胎（rebound）并不是特别健康的做法，对你的……大发雷霆也不是。你知道的，他们会做他们想做的事。你无法控制他们的情绪。
show how that keeps us stuck in a narrative of longing and expectation rather than allowing us to move on. We're also going to touch on ideas of sunk costs, the addiction model of heartbreak, expecting thinking, social comparison, so much more. There is a lot of science behind this that I think could be really, really helpful. But really at the heart of today's episode is what's next? When the chapter finally closes, what do we do? I think it goes without saying that jumping into a new relationship or finding a rebound is not particularly healthy, nor is lashing out at your You know, they're going to do what they want to do. You cannot control their emotions.
当这种情况发生时，我认为我们实际上也是在让自我（ego）压倒理性大脑。事实上，默默地向前看、继续前行才是上策。所以我想过一遍四个关键策略，以便在一段感情结束时最终找到那种接受感，特别是经历了前任似乎找到了别人，以及处理随之而来的所有不适情绪之后。相信我，我知道现在真的很痛，但你会有这种感觉是有原因的，这与人类的心理息息相关。所以我们将在本期节目中探讨所有这些以及更多内容。我很兴奋能深入探讨这个话题，并希望能帮助到处于这种境地的人。你并不孤单。我经历过，也经历这一切，
When that happens, I think what we're really doing also is letting our ego overtake our rational brain. In fact, I think moving on and moving forward in silence is our best bet. So I want to go through four key strategies to kind of finally find that acceptance at the end of a relationship, especially after how X has seemingly found someone else and dealing with all of the uncomfortable emotions that that brings up. Trust me, I know it really hurts right now, but there is a reason you're feeling this way, one that has so much to do with our human psychology. So we are going to explore all of that and so much more in this episode. I'm excited to dive into it and perhaps help someone out there who was in this situation. You're not alone. I've been there, done that,
我都懂。废话不多说，让我们直接切入正题：当你的前任向前看时，你该怎么办。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。
got the t-shirt. So without further ado, let's jump into what to do when your ex moves on. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是数字2%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的节目中。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和李尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here. Unpack went down and tried to make sense of how we survived it.
我是亚历克斯·英格ish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，我们请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一整天可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆到台面上来了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
这是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是成为一个好人。加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，我们就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真正的、真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have really. Real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，兰斯女士，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in selling stress. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱平（Greg Lepin）和迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我简直震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。好了，如果你在听这个，我猜你正处在那个棘手的境地或意识到：你的前任和新欢在一起了。首先，这绝对糟糕透顶，而且在情感上会非常强烈，尤其是如果你们分手不久的话。我对你的处境深表同情，但希望我能从我自己的经历中为你提供一点智慧。我的朋友们其实有个笑话，说我是我所有前任的“寄养女朋友”。他们跟我约会，我修复了他们所有的情感不可得和不成熟，然后把他们送向下一个人，而他们不可避免地会和下一个人开始一段相当长期的关系。我经历过好几次了。这对我来说是不断重复的经历，
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so if you're listening to this, I'm guessing that you are in that tricky place or realization that your ex is with someone new. first of all, that absolutely sucks and it can be so emotionally intense, especially if your breakup was only recently. I feel a lot of sympathy for your situation, but hopefully I can provide you with a bit of wisdom from my own experience. My friends actually have this joke that I'm a foster girlfriend for all of my exes. They date me, I fix all of their emotional unavailability and immaturity, and send them off to the next person who they inevitably start dating. fairly long term. I've been there quite a few times. It is such a repeat experience for me,
但我认为我已经把在这种情况下该做什么总结成了一门科学。这正是我今天真正想分享的。但首先，我们要探讨为什么这段经历会唤起如此多关于拒绝、嫉妒、低自尊以及更多负面感觉，还有愤怒、内疚和困惑。我觉得很有趣的是，我们可以对“这段感情需要结束”这个决定感到无比坦然，直到我们得知有了新人。然后突然之间，所有那些理由似乎都不那么有意义了。希望这不会让你们任何人感到惊讶，显然这种反应背后有大量的心理学原理。
but I think I've gotten it down to a bit of a science as to what to do in this situation. That's really what I want to share today. But firstly, we need to examine why this experience brings up so many negative feelings of rejection, of jealousy, of poor self-worth and so much more, and also anger and guilt and confusion, I find it so interesting that we can feel so fine with our decision that that relationship needed to end until we learn that there was someone new. And then suddenly, all of those reasons don't seem so meaningful anymore. It's not going to surprise any of you, I hope, that there is obviously a lot of psychology behind this reaction.
当我们与某人恋爱时，我们通过共同的回忆、身体接触、亲密感、陪伴、重复的互动，当然还有对未来的期望，与他们建立了非常非常深厚的情感依恋。所有这些经历在心理上都有极强的粘合作用，尤其是像频繁的积极互动这样的事情。它们创造了一种真正的熟悉感和舒适感，并且还会引发生理反应，包括释放诸如催产素之类的荷尔蒙，我们俗称它为“爱情荷尔蒙”。这就是促进这种强烈亲密感的原因。即使你们可能从未正式确立关系，即使那只是一种“情境关系”（situationship），
When we are in a relationship with someone, we develop a very very, deep emotional attachment to them through things like shared memories, physical connection, intimacy, proximity, repeated interactions, and of course an expectation about the future. All of these experiences are incredibly psychologically bonding, especially things like frequent positive interactions. They create a real sense of familiarity and comfort, and they also create biological reactions, including the relationship. lease of hormones like oxytocin, which we colloquially know as the bonding hormone. That is what promotes this intense closeness. Even if maybe you guys were never official, even if it was a
我们的大脑并不理解这些。它们所理解的只是：这里有个人正在满足我的这个需求，为我提供这种亲密感，抚摸我，我信任他——这才是对我们和我们的大脑而言最重要的。当那段关系结束时，这些积极体验的突然终止、脱节以及失去共同未来的痛苦是无比深切的。看到前任和别人在一起，看到他们和新人在一起，会加剧这些感受并引发情感痛苦。我认为之所以特别令人心碎的一个因素是，它让你不得不正视分手的最终结局。当你们都单身时，可能仍然会有这样一种期待感：也许事情会发生变化，特别是当其中涉及未了的情结时。
situation ship, our brains don't understand that. All they understand is here is this person who is fulfilling this need for me, who is providing me with this closeness, who is touching me, who I trust, that is what's important for us and for our brains. When that relationship ends, this abrupt ending of those positive experiences, the disconnect and that loss of a future together is incredibly profound. And seeing someone with your ex, seeing them with someone new, intensifies those feelings and it triggers emotional pain. I think an element of why that is particularly upsetting is because it makes you confront the finality of the finality of the of the breakup. Whilst you were both single, there could still have been this sense of expectation
我们的身体和大脑仍然渴望这个人，因为它不会在一夜之间、甚至在几周内就忘记这种纽带。当他们看似取代了我们时，这就真正巩固了这个章节的结束。不再有任何期待中的事情了。这也是我认为分手真正开始的地方，主要是因为它迫使我们去寻找那种我们以前可能没有的闭环，即那段关系已经结束了。它消除了“如果……会怎样”的想法。有别人坐在了我们的位置上。这就是为什么我认为看到他们和新人在一起会格外痛苦和伤人，因为也许你并没有反思过你真正认为会发生的事情。也许你真的没想过有一天别人会取代你的位置，和那个人在一起，经历所有那些美好的回忆，但你却不在其中。回忆里有了新人。
that maybe things will change, especially when there are unresolved feelings involved there. Our body and our brains still crave this person because it doesn't forget that bond overnight, or even within a few weeks. And when they seemingly replace us, that really solidifies the end of the chapter. There is no more expectant things. it's where I think the breakup truly starts, primarily because it forces us to find that closure that maybe we didn't previously have, that that relationship is done. It eliminates the what if thinking. There is someone else in our shoes. It's why I think seeing them with someone you was particularly kind of painful and hurtful because maybe you haven't reflected on what you really
这里面还有一些其他的心理因素。当我们的前任开始和新人约会时，我们感受到了我们称之为“沉没成本”的全部冲击。有一个概念叫“沉没成本谬误”（sunk cost fallacy），我认为它非常适用于我们对前任做出的决定，特别是如果我们和他们在一起很长时间的话。当我们在一件事情上投入了大量的时间和精力时，我们会对坚持到底并继续把时间投入到这段关系中产生更强烈的承诺感，即使它已经行不通了。原因在于，抽身离去或放弃意味着所有这些资源、所有这些时间都白白流失了，是无法收回的。而当我们曾经投入过的那个人开始和新人约会时，它让我们敏锐地意识到我们放弃了什么，以及我们觉得我们浪费了什么。
thought was going to happen. Maybe you hadn't really thought that someone else would one day be in your position with that person, experiencing all of those beautiful memories, but you're not in them. There's someone new in those memories. There's a few other psychological elements to this as well. When our ex starts dating someone new, we feel the full impact of what we call sunk costs. There's this concept called the sunk cost fallacy that I think really applies to the decisions we make towards ex-partners, especially if we've been with them for a long time. When we invest a lot of time and energy into something,
爱、时间、亲密感。也许这些本可以投入到别的地方。也许这些本可以倾注在更好的人身上。当然，我认为没有任何经历是真正的浪费。有时候，比起从恋爱中获得的，我们从分手中学到的更多，你知道的，从个人经历来看，我无比感激那些受到伤害、不得不看着我曾经爱过的人向前看的经历，因为这深刻地改变了我对自己的看法。我想做得更好。我想变得更好，变得更快乐、更健康，而不是仅仅利用另一个人来消除悲伤。我想从长远来看，我们会为那个选择获得回报。但至少，对于另一个因素，我认为我们之所以很难接受前任这么快就向前看，是因为它将分手非常生理和情感上的余波与更深层的拒绝感和自尊心受损结合在了一起。
we feel a greater sense of commitment to follow that through and to keep putting time into this, into this relationship, even if it's not working. The reason why is because walking away or giving up would mean all of those resources, all of those hours, they're lost, they cannot be recovered. And when this person who we've invested in in the past starts dating someone new, it makes us acutely aware of what we have given up and what we feel like we've wasted. The love, the time, the intimacy. Maybe that could have gone somewhere else. Maybe that
具体来说，我想我们会想他们的决定对我们意味着什么。实际上，这根本说明不了我们什么，但在那种幻想和困惑的状态下。我们认为，如果他们能够这么快就找到新人，如果他们显然已经放下了，这是否意味着我们可以被替代，或者那些感情的强度只是单方面的？或者这是否意味着我身上有什么问题，为什么我还没放下，为什么我还没找到另一个人？分手后，由于缺乏确定性、由于混乱，以及为了重新夺回那些让你在超越那个人的基础上感到独立和独特的个性方面所做出的努力，我们的自尊心已经大大受损了。所以看着他们向前看会让你觉得自己不够好，并让你怀疑这个人曾经对你的所有肯定也许并没有那么特别，尤其是如果你们的联系可以如此轻易地被遗忘的话。如果某人对你很重要，你自然希望他们对你也有同感。
could have been poured into someone better. Of course, I think no experience is ever a waste. We learn more from breakups sometimes that I think we learn from our relationships, you know, from a personal experience, I am so immensely grateful for those experiences of being hurt, having to see someone I once loved move on because it profoundly changed my opinion of myself. I wanted to do better. I wanted to be better, be happier and healthier rather than just using someone else to take away that sadness. And I think in the long term, we are rewarded for that choice. But at least, to this other element as well, and I think the reason we struggle with our ex moving on so quickly is that it combines the very physical and emotional after effects of a breakup with a further
这篇不可思议的文章是这样解释的：当我们看到前任和别人在一起时，这可能会引发对你的伴侣在恋爱期间对你的真实感受的怀疑和不安全感。即使你现在希望你的前任幸福，质疑他们是否真的像他们所说的那样爱你，也是很正常的。这里还有一个因素，如果你你们才分手没多久呢？他们是不是跟别人在一起了？他们是不是早就物色好了？当你们还在恋爱关系中时，他们就已经对你失去兴趣了吗？现在，如果这种经历是一种重复的模式，如果你的前任总是最先向前看的人，这会进一步强化这种错误的信念：不知何故，你是不够优秀的，或者你只是这些人找到真正命中注定的伴侣之前的一个中转站。由此可能会产生强烈的自怜。
sense of rejection and diminished self-esteem. Specifically, I think we wonder what their decision says about us. Really, it doesn't say much about us at all, but in that state of delusion and confusion. We think if they were able to find someone so quickly, if they have apparently already moved on, does that mean we're replaceable or that the intensity of those feelings were one-sided? Or does it mean that there's something wrong with me that I haven't moved on yet, that I haven't found someone else? Our self-esteem after a breakup is already greatly diminished due to that lack of certainty, due to that confusion, and our efforts to reclaim those individual aspects of our identity that make you feel independent and unique beyond that
我经历过。你知道，每次我听说我的前任之一在和新人约会，甚至订婚——这确实发生过，这确实有点刺痛，因为那不是我的经历。但你知道，我是怎么想象的，我总是觉得这些人只是我所踏上的宏伟旅程中的一些龙套角色。他们的章节已经结束了，这对他们来说非常不幸，他们只存在于那一章里，别无其他。他们推动了我的故事和我的成长。而且他们也不欠我什么，但我确实欠他们很多，因为他们只让我变得更好了。你知道，这很有趣，因为我目前其实正在和某人约会，我之前在播客里没怎么提过，你知道，只是为了保护他们的隐私，也为了看看事情会如何发展。但当我们刚开始聊天时，他问我的第一个问题是：上一段感情教会了你关于自己的什么？而我的回答是：它教会了我我配得上什么。
person. So seeing them move on makes you feel inadequate and it makes you question whether everything that this person validated in you is perhaps not that special, especially if your connection could be that easily forgotten. If someone meant a lot to you, it's only natural to want them to feel the same way about you. This incredible article explained it this way. When we see our ex with someone else, this may trigger doubts and insecurities over how your partner truly felt about you in the relationship. Even if you want your ex to be happy now,
他问我，你知道，你配得上什么吗？我告诉他，我知道我的答案。因为在所有那些我被粗暴对待或感到失望的时刻，它们都在向我发出信号，表明这些人的行为没有满足我的需求。我想你的时代终会到来，你也会付出努力成为更好版本的自己，并拥有一段更美好的未来关系。但即使有了这些认识，它也无法减轻你目前所承受的痛苦，因为接下来，当然还有可怕的自我比较——在每一个可能的维度上把自己和他们的新伴侣进行比较。
it's normal to question whether they truly loved you as much as they said they did. There's also this component of if you were only, broke up a little while back? Were they with someone else? Were they already outlooking? Had they already lost interest in you whilst you were still in a committed relationship? Now, if that experience is a repeated pattern, if your ex-partners are always the first to move on, that further reinforces this false belief that somehow you're inadequate or you are just a pit stop before these people, find the person they're really meant to be with. And from that can come an intense self-pity. I've been there. You know, every time I've heard about one of my exes dating someone new or even
我们知道社会比较是完全正常的。这是一个进化过程，它确实让我们能够验证自己的行为，并确保它们符合某些更广泛的社会规范。但是，当我们进行向上社会比较（upward social comparison），特别是与某人的新伴侣进行比较时，如果我们把某人看得比我们好，并因此降低我们自己的自我价值感，这会非常痛苦。我们都知道偷偷去Instagram上视奸他们的新对象的感受，别撒谎，我知道我们都做过，或者，你知道，找一个共同的朋友给你发照片。当然，我们的朋友总是会说同样的话。你知道，她没有你漂亮。她是个降级。他们永远找不到比你更好的人了。而这可悲的是可能并非事实。而且我认为这真的没有必要地让人们，尤其是女性，互相敌对。但这感觉也像是某种安慰奖。
being engaged, it has happened. It does kind of sting a bit because that hasn't been my experience. But you know, how I imagine it, I always think these people were all just kind of side characters in the greater journey I'm on. Their chapter is closed. which is very unfortunate for them, and they only exist in that chapter and nowhere else. They have forwarded my story and my growth. And they also owe me nothing, but I really owe them a whole lot because they've only made me so much better. You know, it's interesting because I'm actually dating someone at the moment, which I haven't
它可能起不到多少作用来尽量减少那个灼热的问题：这个新的人有什么是我没有的？这是一个真正无法回答的问题，会引发自尊心的螺旋式下降，并引发对我们是否具有吸引力的质疑，尤其是当我们尽了最大努力，却依然内心里在乎前任的看法时。我认为这是一种相当讽刺的体验，因为你们俩显然有某种原因没有走到一起。一定有什么原因，无论是距离、不兼容，你知道的，也许你们总是在吵架，甚至是像出轨这样恶劣的事情。然而，就像我之前说的，当我们考虑他们和另一个人在一起会更幸福时，那些原因在那些时刻往往对我们来说就不那么明显了。这就是为什么会这样的原因。这就是所谓的“玫瑰幻觉”的概念。
really spoken about on the podcast, you know, just for their privacy and also to see how things go. But one question he asked me when we first started talking was, what did your last relationship teach you about yourself? And what I said is that it taught me what I deserve. And he asked me, you know, what is it that you deserve? And I told him, I knew my answer. Because in all of those moments where I was treated poorly or disappointed, it acted as a signal to me of a need that these people were not meeting.
这是一种认知偏差，通过这种偏差，我们对过去事件的回忆会比它们实际发生时更美好、更积极。这是因为我们的大脑生来就倾向于记住情感上突出的记忆，而不是那些糟糕的记忆，从而维持一种乐观和希望感。你记得那些美丽亲密的时刻、你们一起去的旅行、拥抱、亲吻、爆发的喜悦，你知道，看到他们，但你压抑了那些让他们让你对自己感觉糟糕的时刻，当有那种焦虑、那些可怕的沉默和那些争吵时，因为那些记忆并不是让我们继续投入的叙事。让我们继续投入的叙事是玫瑰色的回忆和对过去的粉饰。在所有那些美好的回忆中，我们常常渴望一段新事物的开始、一个可以痴迷的新人、一个可以去爱的新人、与他们共同拥有那些回忆以取代旧的回忆，但同时也伴随着这样一种事实：当我们有这种去回忆和感受的冲动时，我们再也无法回到原来的那个源头了。
I guess your time will come and you will have done the work to be a better version of yourself and have a better future relationship. But even with that knowledge, it doesn't diminish the pain that you're currently in because then, of course, there is the dreaded self-comparison and comparing yourself to their new partner on every possible dimension.
所以我想这里需要讨论的重要一点是“备胎”（rebound）的概念。它一定会浮出水面，那个可怕的备胎。我认为在感情结束后我们能做的最糟糕的事情之一，就是利用别人来疗伤、来缝合那个情感伤疤。而且很有可能，如果你的前任在你们分手后几周或一个月内就和某人在一起了，那么这段新恋情的深度将是相当肤浅的。备胎某种程度上占据了前伴侣留下的空间，它提供了稳定感和对失落的转移注意力，而不是去真正克服它。我们之前讨论过“焦虑-分心-反馈循环”（anxiety distraction feedback loop），但我们也可以将其调整为“渴望与痛苦反馈循环”。
We know that social comparison is entirely normal. It's an evolutionary process that really allows us to validate our own behaviours and ensure that they conform to, some broader social norm. But when we engage in upward social comparison, especially with someone's new partner, whereby we see someone as better than us and subsequently reduce our own self-worth, it can be really painful. And we all know that feeling of doing the sneaky Instagram stalk of their new person, don't lie, I know we've all done it, or, you know, finding their own private,
渴望是一种不舒服的感觉，是我们宁愿避开的感觉，但这也是分手后自然会出现的感觉。所以在潜意识里，我们在这种情况下寻求转移注意力。也许那是通过新伴侣的形式，因为那些新的体验让我们能够避免正视那些悲伤的情感。在关于备胎心理学的有限研究之一中，
getting a mutual friend to send you pictures. And of course, our friends are always going to say the same thing. You know, she's not as pretty as you. She's a downgrade. They could never do better than you. And that's sadly probably not the case. And I think it really unnecessarily pits people, especially women, against each other. But it also feels like a bit of a consolation prize.
这些研究人员发现，关注新人实际上特别有助于有焦虑型依恋的人摆脱旧伴侣。而且，你知道，上帝保佑所有曾经体验过当备胎的人。我知道这有多糟糕。我曾经听人说过，我真的帮他走出了前任的阴影，他对我是多么感激。所以向他们致敬。对某些人来说，我注意到了一种竞争感：看谁能最快向前看，谁能赢得这场比赛，谁能向对方证明自己是第一个走出来的人。这可能源于事后往往会爆发的一些内在敌意，但也源于我们在新恋情中获得的某种心理闭环和解脱。当然，性别之间也存在差异。一些自我报告的调查和研究确实表明，男性从分手中恢复的速度比女性快得多，他们也更快地向前看。然而，完全治愈并彻底放下（打上引号）所需的典型时间平均约为六个月。处理这些事情需要相当长的时间。所以如果你的前任在你分手三周后就在发他们的新伴侣，而你正在承受那种刺痛，
It's probably not going to do much to minimize that burning question. what does this new person have that I don't? And it's truly unanswerable and one that can cause such a self-esteem, spiral, and also questions around our desirability, especially when we still inherently care about the opinion of our former partner despite our best intentions. I think it's a rather ironic experience because there was obviously some reason you two didn't work. There had to be something, whether it was distance,
你知道的，“我对他来说真的有什么意义吗？”我可以向你保证。他们多半、绝对还没有忘记你。他们还有很多疗愈工作要做，只是他们可能自己都没意识到。但我认为我们需要做出的心态转变是：那又怎样，如果他们已经忘记了我们呢？为什么他们向前看会困扰你？为什么我们还在乎？尽管我们现在可以回答很多这些问题，你知道的，“缺乏心理闭环”、“如果……会怎样的想法”、“玫瑰幻觉”，下一步就是：现在怎么办？下一步我们该做什么来停止在乎、合上那一章并继续前行？也许不是进入一段新恋情，而是走向一种几乎像精神自由的境界。好吧，这才是今天的真正问题，不是吗？所以我们将在短短几秒钟内深入探讨这个以及更多内容。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
incompatibility, you know, maybe you're always fighting, even something sinister like cheating. And yet, like I said before, those reasons tend to not be so obvious to us in those moments when we are considering them being happier with someone else. There's a reason why this is. It's this concept called rosy retrospection. And it's a cognitive bias whereby we remember past events more fondly and more positive. than they actually were. It's because our brains are primed to remember emotionally salient memories over the terrible ones in order to maintain a sense of optimism and hope. You remember those
看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是数字2%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的节目中。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和李尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。
beautiful intimate moments, the trips you took, the hugs, the kisses, the bursts of joy, you know, seeing them, but you suppress the times when they made you feel terrible about yourself, when there was that anxiety and those awful silences and those fights because those memories are not the narrative that keeps us invested. The narrative that keeps us invested is the rosy recollection and retrospection. And in all of those good memories, we often crave the beginning of something new, a new person to obsess over a new person to love, to have those memories with to replace the old ones, but also the fact that when we have an urge to remember and feel, we can no longer return to the previous source.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格ish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目，我们请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一整天可卡因，只是想让大家知道。
So I think what's important to talk about here is the notion of the rebound. It had to come up, the dreaded rebound. I think one of the worst things we can do after the end of a relationship is to use others to heal to patch up that emotional scar. And chances are, if your ex is with you. someone in the weeks or maybe the month after the end of your relationship, the depth of that new relationship is going to be rather superficial. The rebound kind of takes up the space that was left by the previous partner and it provides both the stability and distraction from the loss
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆到台面上来了，所以。然后你把话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
rather than working through it. We've talked about the anxiety distraction feedback loop before, but we can also adapt that to the longing and distress feedback loop. Longing is an uncomfortable feeling, one that we would rather avoid, but also one that will naturally come up after a breakup. And so subconsciously, we seek out a distraction in this situation. Maybe that's in the form of a new partner because those new experiences allows us to avoid confronting those sad feelings. in one of the limited studies that is available on the psychology of the rebound,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们，
these researchers found that focusing on someone new actually helps anxiously attached people in particular get over their old partner. And, you know, God bless all the people who have experienced being the rebound before. I know how much it sucks. I once had someone tell me that I'd really helped him get over his ex and how grateful he was for me. So shout out to them. For some, I have noticed this sense of competition of who can move on the fastest, who can win
其实已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，或者你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是成为一个好人。
the race, who can prove to the other that they are the first ones to get over it. It probably derives from some of that innate hostility that tends to bubble up after the fact, but also some of that psychological closure and relief that we get from being in a new relationship. And of course, there are also gender differences. Some self-reported surveys and studies do suggest that men recover from breakups much faster than women, and they are quicker to move on. However, the typical time it takes to fully heal and fully in quotation marks, but it's on average around six months. It takes a good amount of time to process things. So if your X is already posting their new person three weeks after you and you're dealing with that sting
加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，我们就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
of, you know, did I really mean anything to them? I can promise you. They most likely, definitely haven't forgotten about you. They've still got a lot of healing work to do that they're probably not even aware of. But I think the mindset shift that we need to have is, so what if they have forgotten about us? Why should it bother you that? they've moved on. Why do we still care? And although we can answer a lot of those questions now, you know, the lack of psychological closure, the what if thinking, the rosy retrosy retrospection, the next stage is now what? What do we do next to stop caring, to close that chapter and move on? Perhaps not into a new relationship, but to a place of almost like mental freedom. Well, that's really the
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，兰斯女士，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破解这个案子。
question of the day, isn't it? So we're going to dive into that and so much more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to. look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through
今日的问题，不是吗？所以我们将在短短一秒钟内深入探讨这个以及更多内容。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中。我剖析了我们这个奇怪现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康健身专家等人交流，越过那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难
some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast.
你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Heart Radio应用上的T-W-O-P-Persent。苹果播客，或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会在这里挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客，大谈80年代的快克毒品。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始发现其中有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病，所以。然后你接着把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们，
are in possession of the thing, and we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
已经拥有了那个东西，但我们还在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真的只是做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索《吃一堑长一智》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of eight. Internet detectives to crack the case.
随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，伦斯女士，对吧？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一支由八名网络侦探组成的队伍来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. To ultimately stop caring, we need to understand the process by which we move on and can provide ourselves with the emotional closure that was perhaps not given to us at the end of the relationship. that lack of emotional closure is I think what really triggers those unpleasant feelings associated
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，亚美科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈指控被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。要最终放下这种在乎，我们需要了解我们继续前行的过程，并为自己提供在感情结束时可能没有给我们的情感解脱。这种情感解脱的缺乏，我认为正是真正引发那些与……相关的不愉快感觉的原因。
with our ex dating someone new. I think when we learn our ex has moved on, we want to do one of two things. Number one is to completely self-isolate, maybe due to the shame of this perceived rejection to kind of lick our wounds, languish in the self-pity, and that's okay. Self-pity feels nice, because it provides us with the emotional validation and the permission to feel sad that perhaps we really need, that we really need to experience. The second option, the second way of doing things, I think is the complete opposite. And it's to go absolutely feral and do everything in our power to move on, particularly by using other people. This is where we download Tinder, we go on a million first dates, we end up in horrendously unfulfilling situationships, we go out
我们的前任有了新对象。我想，当我们得知前任已经开始新生活时，我们往往会做两件事之一。第一种是完全自我封闭，可能是因为这种被拒绝感带来的羞耻感，去舔舐伤口，在自怜中消沉，这其实没关系。自怜感觉挺好，因为它为我们提供了情感上的认可，以及允许我们悲伤的许可，也许这正是我们真正需要的，是我们真正需要去经历的。第二种选择，第二种处理方式，我认为完全相反。那就是彻底放飞自我，竭尽全力地向前看，尤其是通过利用其他人。这就是我们下载Tinder、去进行上百万次初次约会、陷入糟糕得令人窒息的无名关系、每天晚上都出门的原因。
every night. It's really just a defense mechanism for avoiding those confronting emotions, what we would call escapism or displacement. So in psychology, displacement occurs when we satisfy an impulse with a substitute object. You know, we can't get back at our ex by yelling or screaming or by having a fight. So we're going to displace our anger by getting with other people, hoping that that will hurt them the way their decision or their new relationship has hurt us. We want to, in some ways, level the playing field. I think we all inherently know that this initially pleasant sensation of using other people to make us feel better is not going to last. it's just a short-term way of suppressing our true feelings.
这其实只是一种防御机制，用来逃避那些令人面对时感到难受的情绪，也就是我们所说的逃避现实或置换。所以在心理学中，当我们用替代对象来满足某种冲动时，就会发生置换。你知道的，我们无法通过大喊大叫或争吵来对前任进行报复。所以我们要把愤怒转移到其他人身上，希望这能伤害他们，就像他们的决定或新恋情伤害我们那样。我们在某种程度上想要拉平竞争环境。我想我们内心深处都知道，利用别人来让自己感觉好受一些这种最初令人愉悦的感觉是不会长久的。这只是一种压抑真实感受的短期方法。
That is unfortunately not a solution. The age-old saying goes that the only way out is through. You are allowed to feel upset and angry and disappointed. In fact, a lot of those psychological theories surrounding breakups would support this reaction. I want to quickly look at the addiction model and the stages of grief model as an explanation for why we should allow ourselves to feel this hurt deeply and then what to do next. So the addiction model of heartbreak is kind of this psychological concept that likens the experience of heartbreak to that of a drug addiction. It suggests that the emotional pain and the distress that we feel after romantic breakup is similar to the withdrawal symptoms experienced by people trying to break free from a substance.
不幸的是，这并非解决之道。那句老话说得好，唯一的出路就是正视它。你可以感到难过、愤怒和失望。事实上，围绕分手的大多数心理学理论都会支持这种反应。我想快速看一下成瘾模型和悲伤阶段模型，以此解释为什么我们应该允许自己深深地感受到这种痛苦，以及接下来该做什么。因此，心碎的成瘾模型是一种心理学概念，它将心碎的经历比作毒瘾。它表明，在浪漫关系破裂后，我们感受到的情感痛苦和折磨，类似于那些试图戒除物质瘾的人所经历的戒断症状。
addiction. So why is that the case? Well, romantic love and attachment triggers the release of certain neurochemicals in the brain that are very similar to the ones triggered by things like nicotine or things like hard drugs, things like dopamine and oxytocin. Those are associated with the pleasure and bonding we experience in a relationship, but they're also associated with addiction. So when the relationship ends, the sudden withdrawal of these chemicals leads to those feelings of sadness, anxiety, and even physical symptoms like nausea, headaches that are similar to a withdrawal from a substance or from drugs. Just like substance uses my experience cravings, when we're going through heartbreak, we may experience cravings for the presence, affection, and attention of our
成瘾。那么为什么会这样呢？因为浪漫的爱情和依恋会触发大脑释放某些神经化学物质，这非常类似于尼古丁或烈性毒品等事物触发的物质，比如多巴胺和催产素。这些物质与我们在恋爱中体验到的快乐和亲密感有关，但它们也与成瘾有关。因此，当关系结束时，这些化学物质的突然撤离会导致悲伤、焦虑等情绪，甚至出现恶心、头痛等身体症状，这类似于戒毒或戒除某种物质的反应。正如物质使用者可能会经历渴望一样，当我们经历心碎时，我们可能会渴望前任的陪伴、关爱和关注。而这些会导致诸如强塞式思考以及重新联系或复发的愿望，换句话说。
ex-partner. And these lead to things like obsessive thinking and a desire to reconnect or to relapse, in other words. However, these cravings are very much neurological. And when we don't satisfy them by going no contact, by giving it time, they will start to lesson. You have to push those cravings, the withdrawal, the potential for relapse, that temptation, you need to push that out of your mind and really power through in order to rewire your neurochemistry away from this person to more positive things in your life. But this does explain why we hurt so much, but also how we can move forward. Similar to this is what we call the stages of grief. This model is typically used to be applied to what we go through after a death, after someone dies, who we love. But a lot of people
然而，这些渴望在很大程度上是神经层面的。当我们不通过断联、给彼此时间来满足这些渴望时，它们就会开始减弱。你必须将这些渴望、戒断反应、复发的可能性以及这种诱惑推出你的大脑，并真正咬牙坚持，以便将你的神经化学重塑，从这个人转向你生活中的更多积极事物。但这确实解释了为什么我们如此痛苦，同时也解释了我们如何才能向前看。与此类似的被称为悲伤阶段。这个模型通常用于应用于我们经历亲人死亡之后所经历的过程。但很多人确实认为，分手后悲伤的强度与面对死亡时的悲伤非常相似。正如我们之前所解释的，当意识到前任已经开始新生活时，这种悲伤会加剧。那种章节已经关闭的感觉油然而生。那种你不会再见到他们的感觉油然而生。回顾那些美好的回忆会带来真实的痛苦。
do argue that the intensity of the grief after a breakup is very similar to the grief associated with death. As we explained earlier, it can be exacerbated by the realization that your ex has moved on. There is that sense of a closed chapter. There is that sense that you will not see them again. there is a real pain looking back at those positive memories. So to push through that emotional experience, you have to go through five unique states. These are denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and finally acceptance. Denial is your brain's automatic response to unpleasant or unwanted news. It really is a protective mechanism.
因此，要度过那种情感体验，你必须经历五个独特的阶段。它们是：否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁，最后是接受。否认是你大脑对令人不愉快或不想要的消息的自动反应。它确实是一种保护机制。它通过不去真正面对现实，给你的心脏和大脑时间来适应新的局面。在否认阶段，你可能会认为你的另一半、你的前任会回到你身边，因为这最初保护你免受那些不愉快感觉的伤害。你甚至可能处于震惊之中。你无法完全感受到那段感情结束意味着什么。接下来是愤怒。你可能会非常痛恨这个人，因为你所经历的一切。他们所有的消极特质都变得非常非常清晰。你真的、真的很恨。
it gives your heart and your brain time to adjust to the new situation by not really facing reality. In the denial phase, you may think that your significant other, your ex, is coming back to you because it initially protects you from those unpleasant feelings. You might even be in shock. You cannot feel the full extent of what it meant for that relationship to end. Anger is next. You may really resent this person for what. you've gone through. All of their negative qualities are very, very clear. You really, you really hate
他们。但我确实认为，重要的是要记住这只是对你所受伤害的自然反应。你并不是真的恨他们，因为接下来是讨价还价阶段，在这个阶段你可能会试图恢复你们的关系，或者也许将其重建为友谊。这可能是灾难性的。如果你听过我和前任谈论做朋友的那期节目，请明白这正是我，你知道的，非常明确地处于讨价还价的阶段。随之而来的是抑郁，是真正的悲伤。你知道，愤怒和讨价还价，它们感觉非常积极。我们对这个人感到愤怒。我们试图让他们回来。但抑郁是非常安静的。它是非常悲伤的。我认为，真正的分手正是在这里开始的，泪水、悲伤，而且通常我们就是在这里被卡住，似乎无法前行。
them. But I do think it's important to remember it's just a natural reaction to your hurt. You don't really hate them because what comes next is the bargaining phase, where you may try to restore your relationship or perhaps rebuild it as a friendship. This can be disastrous. If you have ever listened to my episode with my ex where we talk about being friends, please just know that this was me, you know, very squarely being in the bargaining stage. And what followed that was the depression, was the real sadness. You know, anger and bargaining, they feel very active. We are angry at this person. We are trying to get them back. But depression is very quiet. It's very sad. It's where the real breakup, I think, begins, the tears, the sadness, and often it's where we get
我认为对于这种情况会持续多久并没有准确的评估，但我认为时间永远是大自然最好的良药，假以时日，所有这些负面情绪都会过去的。我真的、我向你保证。随之而来的是接受。最好也是最后的阶段。正是在这里，我们体验到了所有这些沉重的负面情绪和回忆的释放。归根结底，
stuck and we can't seem to move on. I think there's no accurate assessment as to how long this will stay this way, but I think is always time is nature's best remedy, and in time, all of these negative feelings will pass. I really, I promise you that. And with that comes an acceptance. The best and the final state. it's where we experience the release of all of these heavy emotions and memories. Ultimately,
你会意识到这段感情出于所有正确的理由需要结束，你的状况会更好，你也会没事的。我也认为正是在这个时候，你准备好再次约会了，因为你已经走过了这个自然周期的每一个阶段，也就是恋关系的死亡。如果你的前任进展非常快，甚至在几个月内就开始了新恋情，他们很可能并没有经历过这个过程。所以他们被困在某个中间地带，也许是否认或愤怒，但他们正在利用这段新恋情作为一种分散注意力的手段。
you're going to realize that this relationship needed to end for all the right reasons, that you are better off and you will be okay. I also think that it's at this point that you are ready to date again because you have worked through every stage of this natural cycle, of the death of the relationship. It's likely that if your ex has moved on very quickly, within a few months even, they haven't gone through this process. So they are stuck somewhere in between, perhaps in denial or anger, but they're using this new relationship as a distraction.
与这个理论相关的观点表明，每个人最终都必须经历这些阶段，而在一段新恋情之前你没有疗愈的部分，不可避免地会在你的下一段感情中制造问题。所以我想我们已经确定了你的第一步是什么。第一，你必须允许自己去感受任何在水面下涌动的东西。无论是嫉妒、苦涩、愤怒还是悲伤，每一种情绪都是合情合理的，现在是时候听所有那些棒极了的分手情歌了，去宣泄吧，因为逃避和回避这种状态只会带来更多的压力，尤其是当你对他们和新欢在一起的反应非常糟糕或者感到非常难过时。最近有一项科学研究探讨了回避作为一种应对机制，
The argument attached to this theory suggests that everyone will have to go through these stages eventually and what you don't heal before a new relationship will inevitably create problems in your next relationship. So I think we've established what your first steps are. Number one, you have to allow yourself to feel whatever it is that's bubbling up below the surface. Whether that is jealousy, bitterness, anger, sadness, each of these emotions is valid and it's your time to listen to all of those amazing breakup songs, to wallow because avoidance and avoiding this state is just going to cause more stress, especially if you're reacting very poorly or you're very upset about them moving on with someone new. There was a recent scientific study and it explored avoidance as a coping mechanism,
特别是在一段感情结束时。他们发现，像退缩、顺从、或者太快和新欢开始新生活等行为，与自我同情、转移注意力和升华等积极的应对风格相比，都会产生消极的适应不良的结果。因此，升华尤其强大。这是一种应对机制，我们将那些不可接受的冲动重定向。想要反击、说刻薄的话、所有的伤害，我们把它们引导到积极的事情上。事情是这样的，怨恨和愤怒是极其强大的动力。如果你曾经想跑马拉松、开办新业务或开始新项目，这可能是个绝佳的时机，因为你有如此多的情感能量在寻找一个安全的着陆点，在寻找一个宣泄口。其次，我认为不言而喻，我已经说过无数次了。
especially at the end of a relationship. And what they found was that things like withdrawal, resignation, perhaps moving on with someone new too quickly, they all produced negative maladaptive outcomes compared to active coping styles like self-compassion, like redirection and sublimation. So sublimation is particularly powerful. It's a coping mechanism where we redirect our unacceptable urges
再次强调，千万不要开始一段新的感情，特别是如果这是为了报复前任的行为或新伴侣的话。每个人的疗愈速度大不相同。因此，你需要反思你约会的决定是出于一个有意义的动机，还是出于报复。这里有一个概念叫做重复强迫。因此，如果你过去曾受过伤，你可能会非常忍不住匆忙和那些不适合你的人开始一段新感情，因为你在潜意识里试图修复这种痛苦。但如果你打算再次约会，这里有一些重要的问题需要先问问自己。我是否仍然经常想起我的前任？为什么会这样？我是否还在想象和他们的未来？这段感情教会了我什么，我是否反思过它关于我自己教会了我什么。你真的对结识新朋友感兴趣，还是只是在寻找陪伴？
to lash out, to say cruel things, all of that hurt, and we channel them into something positive. Here's the thing, resentment and anger are incredibly strong motivators. If you have ever wanted to run a marathon or launch a new business or start a new project, this is probably a great time to do it because you have so much emotional energy that is looking for a safe space to land, that is looking for an outlet. Secondly, I think it goes without saying, I've said it at time and time. again, but do not get into a new relationship, especially if it's in retaliation to your exes
你到底在寻找什么？你没有在寻找什么？最后，我还好吗？你还好吗？还是你仍在悲伤？你采取了什么样的应对策略来保护你的平静、保护你的心并完善自己？对这些问题显然没有正确或错误的答案，你的所有答案都将是非常独特的。这更像是一个思考练习，因为我认为如果你诚实地回答了这些问题，你就能得出正确的结论，即你是否真正达到了接受状态，或者你只是在将你的嫉妒或欲望转移到新人身上，或者用陪伴来填补那个空虚。第三，如果你的前任已经向前看了，请占据道德制高点。俗话说，我认为。
actions or new partner. People are going to heal at very different speeds. So you need to reflect on whether your decision to date is coming from a meaningful place or one of vengeance. There's this idea called repetition compulsion. So if you have been hurt in the past, you can be very tempted to rush into a new relationship with people who are wrong for you because you're subconsciously trying to fix the pain. But here are some important questions to ask yourself first if you're planning on dating again. Am I still regularly thinking about my ex? Why is that? Do I still imagine a future with them? What did that relationship teach me and have I reflected and what it has taught me about myself. Are you actually interested in meeting new people or are you just seeking companionship?
成功才是最好的复仇，不是因为它给另一个人带来了什么，而是因为它给你带来了什么。在沉默中前行，无需他们的参与，也无需让他们知道，去经营一个美丽的人生。我认为，当你允许自己的情绪压倒你并接管控制权时，你真正做的是让你的自我来控制你的决定。不要给他们发信息诉说他们多么伤害了你。不要出现在他们门前。不要在社交媒体上发布任何长篇大论的发泄，你的沉默和你的平静是你手头最强大的武器。同样重要的是，要反思你的单身生活带给你的所有美好事物，而不是对前任及其新恋情状态怀恨在心。这真是一个。
What are you actually looking for? What are you not looking for? And finally, am I okay? Are you okay? Or are you still grieving? And what kind of coping strategies have you put in place to protect your peace, protect your heart and better yourself? There are obviously no right or wrong answers to these questions, all of your answers are going to be very much unique. It's more of a thinking exercise because I think if you answer these questions honestly, you will be able to come to the right conclusion about whether you have truly reached acceptance or you are just displacing your jealousy or your desires onto someone new or feeling that whole with companionship. Thirdly, if your ex has moved on, take the higher ground. As the saying goes, I think
重要的心理练习，因为我认为如果我们没有伴侣，我们在社会上往往会觉得没有价值。我们面临着这种污名，这种认为我们应该努力走向新恋情的看法。而这样做的后果，就是让我们最终在错误的时间、和错误的人、陷入错误的感情中。当然，看到前任似乎陷入了一段非常幸福的新恋情，并认为我们也应该拥有那样的生活，这会加剧这种感觉。但单身带来了无比强烈的自由感和独立感。这具有无价的价值，尤其是在我们20多岁的这个人生十年里，我们的身份认同仍在很大程度上成型。
success is truly the best revenge and not because of what it brings the other person, but because of what it brings you. Move forward in silence, cultivate a beautiful life without the need for their input, without needing them to know about it. When you allow your emotions, I think, to overwhelm you and take control, what you're really doing is giving your ego control over your decisions. Don't message them saying how much they've hurt you. Don't show up at their door. Don't post. any long rants on social media, your silence and your peace are the most powerful things at your disposal. It's also important to reflect on all the good things your singleness brings you, rather than that bitterness towards your ex and their new relationship status. This is such an
你有更多的时间留给自己的爱好、锻炼、与朋友度过有意义的时刻，我认为还可以去旅行，而不会觉得你错过了什么或错过了某人。你只是真正地更了解自己了。这是那些从一段感情跳到另一段感情的人所无法比拟的，因为他们试图压抑某些情绪或某种深层的痛苦。这种心态的转变：从“他们向前看了，我好痛苦，我好孤独，我永远找不到人了”，转变为“单身简直太棒了！我完成了那么多事情，我感到如此自由，我太快乐了”。
important mental exercise because I think we often don't feel valued in society unless we have a partner. And we face this stigma, this perception that we should be striving towards a new relationship. And what this does is it causes us to end up in the wrong relationships at the wrong time with the wrong people. This is, of course, going to be exacerbated by seeing our ex in apparently a very happy new relationship and thinking that we should have that as well. But being single brings such a sense of freedom and independent. that is insanely valuable, especially in this decade of life and our 20s, when our identity is still very much being formed.
这真的能让你从受害者心态转变为英雄心态，或者进入一个深刻的主动掌控状态。这也是投资于你自己的发展和自我价值的绝佳时机。你知道的，你在听这个播客，所以我认为你已经走在了正确的轨道上，选择你生活中想要改善的一个领域，并朝着那个更高的结果和最高版本的自己努力，而不是去寻找一段新的感情。你知道的，不要去反刍关于你身上导致那段关系结束或导致你的前任如此迅速地向前看的所有错误。我们生命中有如此之少的时间。
You have more time for your hobbies, for exercise, for meaningful moments with friends, I think also to travel without feeling like you're missing something or you're missing someone. You just genuinely know yourself better. And that's something that cannot be said for people who jump from one relationship to the next because they are trying to suppress some emotion or some deep pain. This mindset shift from, I'm so miserable that they moved on, I'm so lonely, I'm never going to find someone to, you know, how amazing is it to be single? I get so much done, I feel so free, I'm so happy.
当我们真正独处，不承担他人的负担或对他们情绪的责任时。所以你真的需要拥抱这个阶段。我说的是每天散步。我说的写日记、保持干净的房间、清醒的头脑、如果可以的话进行规律的心理治疗，以及培养美好的友情。培养美好而深刻的自我觉察和自我价值。我记得在我上一次分手后，我真的进入了拥抱我内心的神圣女性特质的领域。我写下自己的肯定语，我听那些让我感到强大的音乐，我把每一天都视为我和前任之间多走的一步，是他们一无所知的又一天。当他们不可避免地向前看时，我真的不在乎，因为我已经做了我需要做的所有工作，我只是真的希望。
That really allows you to shift from a victim mentality to a hero mentality or to a profound place of agency. it's also an amazing time to invest in your own development and self-worth. You know, you're listening to this podcast, so I think you're already on the right track, but choose one area in your life that you want to improve and work towards that higher outcome and that highest version of yourself rather than looking for a new relationship. You know, rather than ruminating on everything that was wrong with you that caused, that relationship to end or caused your ex to move on so quickly. There are so few times in our lives
他们能幸福。我走进了我的力量、我的主控权，我超级专注于成为最好的自己，我没有把开始新生活视为一场竞争，我也没有把它视为他们取代了我，对吧？他们找到了一个对他们更好的人，我会找到一个对我有更好的人，这就是我们所能期望的一切。就是这样。而且我认为一段新恋情是无法带给我这些的，反弹式恋情也无法带给我，它无法满足那种需求以及我为自己所需要做的工作。你知道，归根结底，你不是你的感情状态。如果你的前任选择非常快地和别人开始新生活，他们并没有做你将有特权去做的那些工作。
when we are truly alone and not carrying the burdens of others or responsibility for their feelings. So you really need to embrace this chapter. I'm talking the daily walks. I'm talking journaling, a clean room, a clear mind, regular therapy, if you can, and cultivating beautiful friendships. cultivating beautiful and deep self-awareness and self-worth. I remember after my last breakup, I really kind of went into this realm of embracing my inner divine feminine. I like wrote out my affirmations. I listened to music that made me feel powerful and I saw every day as one more step between me and my ex, one more day that they knew nothing about. And when they inevitably moved on, I truly didn't care because I'd done all the work that I needed to do and I really just wanted
当那段感情不可避免地破裂时，他们会在六个月后发现自己处于你现在的位置。而且你看不见闭门后的所有挣扎。你看不见他们脑子里在想什么。他们可能只是那种需要不断通过利用别人来填补自己情感伤口的人。而这绝对不是任何听这个播客的人会成为的那种人。作为最后的提醒，我只想送上一些爱。我深深地知道这有多痛，那种被遗忘或被取代的感觉是怎样的，事实并非如此。绝对不是这样的。即使真的是这样，那也解放了你。那真的允许了。
them to be happy. I'd stepped into my power, my agency, I was so hyper-focused on being the best version of myself and I didn't see moving on as competition and I also didn't see it as them replacing me, right? They found someone that was better for them and I'll find someone that's better for me and that is all that we can kind of hope for. And that's something. And that's something that I think a new relationship wasn't going to give me, a rebound wasn't going to give me, it wasn't going to fulfill that need and the work I needed to do for myself. You know, at the end of the day, you're not your relationship status. And if your ex is choosing to move on really quickly with someone else, they haven't done the work that you are going to have the privilege to do.
你去做你需要做的工作，并允许你继续前行，因为他们某种程度上，他们已经做出了决定。他们已经把牌摊在了桌面上。而且我认为它确实提供了脱离一段经历、一段感情或一个前任所必需的情感和心理上的解脱。所以他们真的帮了你一个大忙。他们为你提供了一项服务。非常感谢你收听今天的节目。我真的很喜欢。我认为观察为什么我们会有这种感觉、为什么这是正常的背后的科学和心理学，并消除其中的一些羞耻感，是非常迷人的。而且，那种感觉，你知道，“哦，我不应该感觉不好。我不应该为此感到难过。”
They're going to find themselves where you are now in six months time when that relationship inevitably falls apart. And you don't see all the struggles behind closed doors. You don't see what's going on in their mind. They may just be one of those people who needs to constantly be healing their emotional wounds by using others to fill them, essentially. And that's not the kind of person that anyone listening to this podcast is going to be. And as a final reminder, I just want to extend some love. I know so deeply how much much this hurts, how it feels to perhaps be forgotten or feel replaced, that is not the case. That is definitely not the case. And even if it was, that has freed you. That has really allowed
你知道的，你完全应该感到难过。如果你想感到难过，这对于分手、余波以及被拒绝的经历来说，是一种完全正常、自然的心理反应。所以我希望这期节目真的对你有所帮助。一如既往，如果你的生活中有人正在经历这一切，他们的前任非常快地开始了新生活，你应该把这个发给他们。我真心希望他们能从中有所收获。如果你确实喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。
you to do the work that you need to do and allowed you to move on because they have kind of, they've made their decision. They've put their cards on the table. And I think it actually does provide the emotional and psychological closure that is necessary to fully be liberated from an experience or from a relationship or from an ex-partner. So they have really done you a solid. They have done a service for you. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. I really enjoyed it. I think it is so fascinating to look at the science and the psychology behind why we feel this way, why it is normal and to kind of eliminate some of that shame. And, and that sense of, you know, oh, I shouldn't feel bad. I shouldn't feel sad about this.
如果你想要更多内容、更多额外剧集，请关注我们的Patreon。我真的很感谢大家在那里给予我的一切支持。最后，天哪，我在这些节目结尾的闲扯、唠叨变得越来越长了。我需要对此做点什么。但如果你还没有在Instagram上关注我，我的账号是that psychology podcast。如果你有节目建议，事实上，我们正在寻找一些新点子。所以发过来吧，我们可能会考虑一下。非常感谢今天的收听。祝你们一切都好。送上我满满的爱。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，各位最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯为您带来的《艰难求生》。
You know, you totally should feel sad. If you want to feel sad, it's a completely normal, natural psychological reaction to a breakup, to the after effects, to an experience of rejection. So I hope that this episode has really helped you. As always, if there is someone in your life who is having this experience right now, whose ex has moved on really quickly, you should send this to them. I really hope that they get something out of it. If you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是有电梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学知识。
And if you want more content, more bonus episodes, please follow along at our Patreon. I really appreciate all the support you have provided me over there. And finally, oh my gosh, my ramble, my spiel at the end of these episodes, is becoming very long. need to do something about that. But if you're not already following me at Instagram, I'm at that psychology podcast. If you have an episode suggestion, actually, we're looking for some new ideas. So send it over and we might just have a look into it. So thank you so much for listening today. I'm wishing you all the best. I'm sending you so much love. And we will be back next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字的TWO percent，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时。她们决定自己动手丰衣足食。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental
他不会就这么逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same. prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
在1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
In 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
1979年，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同仁喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。
84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯过去》。这是一个IHeart播客。百分百真人。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子以留下评论。